Steve Kerr Continental Tire coaches
corner as we bring in head coach a
golden state coach how are you this
morning I'm good how you doing no
complaints how highly recruited were you
out of high school I is a joke or way
you went to Arizona so you had to be
highly regarded I did I finished my
senior year of high school without a
scholarship offer I got a late I kind of
late recruit like it was summer league
in in LA and I got two scholarship
offers at the very last second Arizona
and Cal State Fullerton so not very
highly recruited who plays today in the
NBA the way you played I I don't know
that's that's good question I've never
even thought about it I mean there's you
know I was a spot-up shooter and kind of
a combo guard I didn't you know I didn't
I didn't law anybody so I don't I don't
think there's anybody out there who just
you know jumps out as well that guy was
just as mediocre advice would you be
more valuable today in today's game not
necessarily mean you know people ask me
that all the time the way the
three-point shot has has taken off you
know if I would be more effective
I mean offensively yes but defensively I
think I would I would struggle more
because you know the game has gotten so
fast and if you're not a point guard
then you need to be you know a six six
wing who can guard multiple positions
and you know when I played I remember
when I first started playing there were
a bunch of guys who played the two
guards spot who were my size you know
Jeff hornacek and Hershey Hawkins and
Trent Tucker guys who were you know 6-3
6-4 but these days you know you got
basically everybody's kind of built in a
similar fashion every team you got you
got Steph Curry or you know James Harden
or somebody playing your point guard
spot who is unbelievably dynamic you
know Kyrie
and then you've got wing shooters who
are who are really big and versatile
defensively so it's it's a different
game
how many more threes do you think Jordan
would have taken if he played in today's
game probably a lot more you know he
really didn't work at it that much mean
he was such a mid-range guy who's a
post-up player but you look at LeBron
you know early in his career he wasn't
really much of a 3-point shooter but
because the game was trending that way
you could see he shot more and more of
them all the time and I think I think if
Michael were playing today he would have
gone in that direction and taken a lot
more threes he ever Duncan an NBA game
no I've never even Duncan practiced and
you've never done before well you know
what I would do is like once a year in
the NBA we you know we would practice at
all these different spots and every once
while you'd practice like maybe it's a
New York Athletic Club or some in there
there'd be that one rim that was
actually about 99 I'd go over to that
hoop
I'd feel like if I felt really good that
day and like my teammates would actually
gather around be like come on you can do
this so you put on a dunking display I
wouldn't call it a display you know I'd
like people possibly just sort of
force-feed one ball over the rim like
early and I just did just to show that I
might be able to do it
condoms hire coaches corner Steve Kerr
the Warriors joining us got the Rockets
coming up tonight I don't know if it's
the best time to ask it considering who
you're playing but who would you vote if
you were still a member the media for
MVP yeah I'm not going to answer that
because however I am sure he will be
used against me in incriminating - what
is it about Harden okay tell me the
difference between the two harden in
Westbrook the biggest difference is what
well their teams are so different for
one thing so it's a totally different
challenge when you when you play each
one of them and you know we've got
Houston tonight there's so much court to
cover with Harden because of the
shooting that he's got around and they
play a different style Oklahoma City is
a big strong team and they're going to
try to muscle you inside and so you
don't have to get out as far to the
three-point line but both guys are so
good just in attacking the rim and
getting into the paint and putting you
on your heels and you know it's you go
into each game just mainly concerned
with with those two guys I mean that's -
you know the head of the snake is the
expression people use in it and it's
true those close you guys really
everything revolves around them with
their respective teams and and you go in
with with a lot of trepidation because
they can both do a lot of damage it's
interesting when you see players in
college and then you wonder how that
translates into the pros did you see
anything with Westbrook and or hardened
where you would have gone okay those
guys have a chance to be something
special yeah you know I watched harden
and when he was at ASU because I was
with the Suns and as a GM and so I saw
him a lot and you could see that he was
a gifted passer and you know you it was
it would have been hard to imagine all
of this but I thought it was pretty easy
to see that he was going to be a hell of
a player but this you know like a lot of
guys who end up being an MVP like Steph
Curry you know you can't really quite
envision it because you don't really
know what's inside a guy and what how
he's going to react to being in the
league how he's going to handle himself
how he's going to work and how he's
going to develop but I thought I thought
Harden you could see it a lot easier
with Harden in college than you could
with Westbrook Westbrook was amazing but
he was he was just an athlete you feel a
like he didn't even play point guard
really and I he was there for two years
and he was just so explosive but it was
harder to see like what he would become
or as harden I think you could
kind of see the the game the the passing
ability that kind of the all-around
nature of his play how much stock did
you put and do you put in two tournament
play with what you see with these kids
you know that regular season and
postseason or postseason separate from
the regular season yeah I don't think
you should put too much in it and again
I gotta be careful I can't mention any
college players so please don't lead me
down that path you've got me fine in or
- I know I ten ten grand seven years ago
that's right glad you remember that yeah
I am I'm trying to forget it but I can
every time I talk to you I feel bad I
bring it up but no I think it's
important not to get too wrapped up in
that because it is it is just one game
and you do have to watch a guy you know
all season long but if I remember
correctly Hardin did not have a grade no
tournament no and I don't know if that
cost him I told was he about maybe the
fourth or fifth pick yeah drop me it was
third so I don't think it cost him too
much but yeah you can't you can't get
too wrapped up in that it's one game the
whole sitting out players are shortening
the season or I I think everybody's in
agreement here but we can't be in
agreement of how to rectify all of this
so and I don't know if being the coach
of a great team a marquee team a team
that's going to be on TV
does it hurt you more than it helps you
that you're a must-see TV team well I
think the schedule has hurt us you know
I have we loved being on TV I think it's
great being part of a team that
everybody is watching and first of all
I've only rested my main guys I think
twice in three years so this is not
something that I've done routinely I
routinely rested Livingston and Iguodala
based on age and wear and tear and we've
done that probably three or four times a
year since I've been here
but staff clay draymond I think those
guys have rested about this was the
second time I've done it in three years
so it's not a not a routine but the
schedule was was insane it really was
and I thought that was based on the NBA
trying to create national TV
yeah and so that hurt and and that's
something that I've talked to Adam
silver about and and I think the league
is going to do a much better job next
year of recognizing that you know we
can't just you know pepper the schedule
with these cross-country trips in a
two-week span and we literally were in
eight cities and 880 games in eight
cities over 13 days and we traveled
across the country twice and our guys
were spent they were exhausted and we
think we're traveling more than anybody
else this year by a wide margin and I
think that's where the league can really
help is trying to make the schedule more
geographically sensible last time i
Kevin Durant traveling with with the
team yeah yeah he's on the trip and he's
looking good I mean he's we're not going
to really know for another you know a
couple we probably 10 days or so that's
that's when he's gonna be reevaluated by
the doctors but he's coming along and
he's doing a little bit more each day on
the court and he looks good what if I
said let's put it to a vote with the
players and the coaches 70 games
season-high okay yeah you know I think
it's a good idea I mean I actually Bill
Simmons had a good idea had 76 games and
and the reason he came up with 76 I
think he said you play every team in the
in the other conference twice like you
do now
but in your own conference you play all
your divisional teams four times and
everybody else in your conference not in
your division three times so there's
actually some some symmetry and the
reason I like that was 76 sounds about
right to me and in terms of you know it
feels as a coach like there's five or
six games a year that are sort of throw
aways like we have no chance tonight
based on the schedule and I don't think
you can cut too many games but I think I
think chopping six off to me makes a lot
of sense and it would help a lot
physically but I think it would I think
it would help the players quite a bit
but I don't really know what
would mean to the economic model and you
know all that stuff
have fun against Hardin tonight there
see yeah yeah it's going to be a lot of
thanks for joining us great to catch up
with you
alright thanks dad that's Steve Kerr
warriors head coach Continental Tire
coaches corner there the exclusive tire
the Dan Patrick show no matter where you
drive or what you drive Continental
designs tires for what you do for more
information visit cone general tire calm
continental time for what you do the Dan
Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience